okay so let's continue our
of welfare economics just to review
where we are the first set of lectures
in the course were about positive
economics about understanding where
supply and demand curves come from and
what they mean now last lecture we
turned from positive to normative
economics and actually making judgments
about whether things are good or bad and
when choose the concept of welfare
economic welfare or well-being and we
talked about consumer surplus which is a
measure of how well-off consumers are
made by given exchange of goods and
services and producer surplus how
well-off police's are made we're going
to start our lecture by proving what's
modestly called the first fundamental
theorem of welfare economics which is
that competition maximizes welfare so
this is basically taking our positive
economics at a meeting our normative
economics that is we are going to talk
about how the model we've derived so far
which is the equilibrium and a perfect
competition happens to also be the
outcome that delivers the maximum
well-being to society let's step back
well-being we called welfare how do we
define the well-being of society well
we're going to start with a simple
definition which is we're gonna sadly
say that social welfare social welfare
is the total welfare of society is
simply consumer surplus plus producer
surplus that is we're not going to put
any different weights we're not going to
say we like somebody better than another
which is because they look surplus is
produced by a transaction and we just
care about the total surplus that's
produced and later we can come down via
about consumers versus producers and we
will but right now let's just say we
care about the total surplus that's
produced for society how much benefit is
produced by this transaction ok well the
benefits produced by this transaction is
going to be the surplus derive surplus
generated for consumers by that
transaction and the surplus generated
for producers by that transaction so our
total measure of social well-being is
going to be the sum of consumer and
producer surplus and we are going to
prove as I said we you don't need to
know this but it's in graduating I was
called the first fundamental theorem of
welfare economics
which is that under the assumptions
we've made which are many okay under the
assumptions we've made the competitive
equilibrium where supply equals demand
is the point that maximizes social
welfare that is the key insight is the
point that the market naturally delivers
the equilibrium that's gained by the
market naturally happens to be the point
that also makes society as well off as
possible a very profound result okay
that is a positive conclusion which is
that supplying a man will meet at a
certain equilibrium delivers a normative
conclusion which is that equilibrium is
the point which maximizes social welfare
okay now the best way to see this is
just graphically so let's go to figure
10:1 okay figure ten one has supply and
demand curve okay once again whether
these are curved or linear these are
just you know it's still the basic idea
of supply and demand curve so a curve
supplying a main curve are things which
more are more sort of constant
elasticity type curves but that doesn't
really affect the intuition okay we have
here the triangles of consumer surplus
and producer surplus so consumer surplus
give me the letter somebody raise their
hand and tell me which letters on this
diagram correspond to consumer surplus
and Y which which areas denoted by which
letters correspond to consumer surplus
and why yeah why is that
exactly everything above below the
demand curve above the price consumer
surplus so R plus V so therefore what's
producer surplus same person s plus T
plus U is producer surplus so consumer
surplus R plus V producer surplus is s
plus t plus u okay you can see those of
you are sort of graphically oriented can
immediately see the sum of those two
triangles will be maximized at the
intersection of the curves and nowhere
else okay so for example let's think
about the case where I say well look
it's a shame the prices that high we
ought to make the price lower let's set
a new price let's have the government
mandate a new price at p2 suppose the
government intervenes and since we're
gonna set a price ceiling we're gonna
say no one can charge more than p2 for
their product and won't that be a good
thing because consumers ould be better
off they'll pay lower prices well what
does that do that does what does that do
to consumer surplus
well consumer surplus used to be R plus
V it instead becomes R plus s which is
bigger
okay consumer surplus Rises you lose the
triangle V and you gain the and you gain
the rectangle S but the key point is at
the price e to okay at the price P to
yet that becomes the new consumer
surplus the new producer surplus is what
at that price p2 what's the new producer
surplus so raise their hand and tell me
yeah it's T it drops to t producers just
get below the price above the supply
curve so what has happened to total
social welfare it has fallen by the
amount V Plus u total social welfare has
fallen play deepest V Plus u so in some
sense two things have happened here
we've set this price the first is a
transfer we have transferred the
rectangle s from producers to consumers
s used to be part of producer surplus
we're not giving it to consumers first
thing that happens is a transfer that
was probably the idea of this policy
make consumers better off so who
transferred what you see pretty surplus
to consumers that's the rectangle s
that's the first thing this happened so
thing one this happened is a transfer of
s but the second thing that's happened
is we have created what we call a
deadweight loss of U plus V a deadweight
loss of U plus V dwl deadweight loss
what does the deadweight loss that is
the net reduction in welfare from trades
that are not made the deadweight loss is
a key concept we'll come back to I'll
expect you to know it in your sleep okay
is that deadweight loss is the net
reduction in Social Welfare from trades
that are not made the intuition here is
that every trade that makes at least one
party better off without making the
other party worse off is a good trade to
do under the assumption we made so far
if you ever trade that increased
consumer surplus or produce surplus or
both that's a good thing to have right
if my daughter has any song she wants to
buy by Kendrick Lamar that you guys have
more than a dollar she gets him for a
dollar anything which stops her from
buying those songs is bad she's losing
surplus okay so basically the key point
is that deadweight loss is an
inefficiency okay we talked about how
competition leads to maximally efficient
production through cost minimization
competition also leads to the maximum
welfare outcome because that point is
the point which makes society best off
defined as the sum of consumer surplus
plus producer surplus
okay but once again I cannot highlight
enough the depth of this insight at this
point which before today you knew as the
outcome I showed him the first lecture
this what happens we have supply and
demand you get to this equilibrium that
happens to be the very best place to be
and that's why we call it the first
fundamental theorem it's very important
okay yeah so so so let's I want to come
to that let's talk about that let's go
to another example to talk about that
let's talk about interventions let's do
it let's do it let's do an example let
that was just sort of to teach you the
basic idea but let's go on to more
explicit example of a government
intervention actually do it here let me
do explicit example of a government
intervention that will and that will
address the question was just asked
because I skipped over sort of a key
point here that that I'm always I'm
always not sure whether way order to
teach you things so so let's ask let's
take an example of a market let's
consider the market for gas so go to
figure 10 to this heart we talked about
before the market for gas
imagine the market for gas is initially
in equilibrium with supply curve s1 and
a demand curve D it's initially in
equilibrium at Point little E one with
q1 gallons of gas being sold at a price
p1 that's the initial equilibrium now
imagine that there is an oil crisis
because for example low company cited be
good idea to drill 8 miles underground
horizontally and the busts and their
spills everywhere something like that
some random example like that ok and
this was a supply crisis what happens
now is suddenly it gets more expensive
to produce gas so the supply curve
shifts upwards we talked about this last
time leading us to new equilibrium at
Point E - and your we talked about the
echolert mork's firt initially there if
we think about in steps initially you've
created an excess demand because gas
companies no longer want to supply
q1 Gallants at a price p1 from their new
supply curve so you move you shift along
the demand curve to the new point e 2
which is new equilibrium and all's well
and good
okay prices go up that's what happened
after deepwater and things like that
okay now imagine the government doesn't
like that magic government says well we
don't like that we don't like the fact
consumer is a table for gas consumers
vote us out of office we'll have to pay
more for gas so we are gonna solve this
by imposing a price ceiling we're gonna
announce the price of gas must remain at
its old level p1 okay
so let's go to figure 10 three figure 10
three shows what happens when the
government imposed that price ceiling
okay well the first question is if the
government imposed a price ceiling of p1
how much actually gets sold in the
market this comes the question was just
asked well this is sort of a new thing
this sort of a new thing we've looked at
which is we have the situation was
excess demand at the price p1 could
sumers still want Q little deep but
suppliers are only willing to supply Q s
cute little s see consumers still are
working off the same demand curve if
used the government says we still want
the price to be p1 they're like great we
someone as much gas we had before
suppliers are like no way we're not
going to supply it if you're gonna keep
the price at that level we're gonna
produce less gas because we haven't
rising marginal cost so if you're gonna
force have that same price we're gonna
work our way back down the supply curve
and produce less gas so suddenly you
have a situation of excess demand that
doesn't get resolved remember the last
time I said excess demand I resolved by
moving up the demand curve well you
can't hear you can't resolve that
because the price is forced to be a p1
ok now what determines what actually
gets sold ones a price restriction
here's the way I like to think of it I
like to think of the actual quantity
gets set by the constrained party so in
this case a price ceiling means that
suppliers want our ask supply more than
they're willing to so they just say no
so you actually get the ultimate quality
in the market is qsr it doesn't matter
that demand is yqd they can't buy stuff
that's not produced likewise we'll do
examples later with a price floor where
suppliers where could worship where
consumers want less the suppliers want
it but will provide then its consumers
that decide what gets sold so mace
whoever wants less gets to decide
because you can't force the producers to
produce more we don't know we have a
private oil industry gas industry so you
end up with qsr units of gas sold at a
price p1 so what the price ceiling does
is move you from e1 to e3 you would have
moved to e2 without the government
intervention instead it moves you to e3
ok and as a result you end up with
consumers consumer surplus being a plus
C producer surplus being e and relative
to an unconstrained world I wrote over
before but relative without government
intervention you have a deadweight loss
of B plus D yeah well that's a very deep
question the guy says that we don't have
a nationalized gas industry we just have
private gas industries there's a
separate issue you know a larger issue
about whether private or public sector
should be producing things and that's
sort of beyond the scope of what we're
discussing here but for now assume the
government just has a regulatory role
not a gas production role the government
by the way does have a little gas
production role because the government
actually something called the strategic
oil reserve where they have millions of
barrels they can actually release and
release out in the market at certain
times the government does have a way try
to deal with this but for now let's
assume that I could use the strategic
reserve just regulate price ok so they
regulate price and what they've done is
they've created a deadweight loss ok so
basically if we think about it what are
the costs and benefits of government
intervention the costs of government
intervention are twofold
what are the costs of this price ceiling
there's two costs cost one is you've
created an inefficiency you've created
you straighten this deadweight loss
because basically if you didn't restrict
things there are people who would have
bought gas to the right of Q sub s and
to the left of e to those units between
Q sub s and E to worry to intersects the
x axis those are units where the
consumer surplus plus the Bruce surplus
is positive right you look at the unit
right to the right of Q sub s that's a
unit that would have that consumers
would have happily bought at the new
higher price and producer would have
happily sold the new higher price but
the government isn't letting it happen
so that's a deadweight loss so that's an
inefficiency okay so that's the first
cost the cost of society of trades that
don't get made and we call this an
efficiency loss because there are
efficient trays trake things are
efficient if they make the whole the
joint surplus is positive if I net
people are better off there are fishing
trades
which both sides were happy to make and
they can't mate and they can't make so
we call us an efficiency loss okay but
that's not the only cost to this policy
what's the other cost it's a hard
question yeah so this enforcement you
have to like go around send regulars
around the gas stations make sure
they're not charging the wrong price
that's true I sort of make that small
let's take more sort of a theoretical
not theoretical but what's the other big
source of what yeah
there's sort of a dynamic but once again
the producers think this may be a
short-run thing and what's the pro you
know once the deepwater horizon gets
fixed they'll prices will be back down
or whatever but what's the other miracle
of the market that we lose here what
time is the very first lecture yeah but
that's one lets rule out of choice
because just a short-run deal yeah yes
there's allocated inefficiency remember
one of the things we talked about in the
very first lecture I think we did maybe
not
anyway one of the most important
benefits of the competitive equilibrium
it doesn't just deliver the right
quantity it delivers it to the people
who want it the most so if you think
about let's go back to figure 10 - it's
easy to see there if you think about who
gets gas at the initial equity one and
actually no but let's go ten three
that's fine so let's say we hadn't
interfered and we'd allowed the price to
go to e - well fewer people would've
bought gas right supply the quantity
would have fallen from QD would have
fallen all the way from e1 to e2 but the
people who dropped out would have been
who the people who value gas - the least
the people who got the lowest surplus
from it okay however now suddenly you
only have qsr units of gas and you have
QD people who want them well now who
decides who gets them before the market
did the magic the market made sure the
people who wanted the unit's got them
now of a sudden something else has to
decide so how do you resolve this well
we actually had an answer to this we had
a gas crisis in the 1970s and the
government imposed the price ceiling and
have it get resolved how do we decide
then who got the gas does anyone know
raise your hand tell me if you know yeah
people wait in line people basically sat
in their cars and waited in line okay
now so essentially if you think about it
we goods are going to get allocated
somehow if the market isn't allocate
them there'll be another less efficient
allocation mechanism okay and basically
why is it inefficient that people waited
in line for gas there's actually two
reasons one sort of cute but what's the
main reason officially waiting in line
for gas yeah yes the opportunity cost
little point little one you have the
opportunity cost okay you have the fact
that that time I spent waiting in line I
could have been working or having fun
but certainly something I would've
enjoyed more than waiting line for gas I
think we'd all agree that there's
something we'd rather be doing with our
time than waiting in line for gas okay
unless you really like the music getting
your car stereo you can't listen
anywhere else I don't know what the
story would be but I can't imagine that
many of us would prefer to wait in line
for gas do something else does the
opportunity cost that's it inefficiency
society is losing out because you are
not using your time in the most
productive way and the way that maximize
your welfare okay so there's that what
else what's the other small other cost
yeah yeah people use gas waiting in line
so there's literally the technical and
efficiency and remember this is like
back when cars got like eight miles to
the gallon so you'd like get to the
front line get gas let's go back to the
back of the line again because use so
much gas plus not to mention the
pollution all that other stuff so
basically this is the inefficiency from
an on market allocation mechanism okay
which is that people could be doing more
productive things and not wasting gas
waiting in line yeah
ya know QD month because we fixed the
price of p1 so it's QD months cute since
we Prix the fysop re1 people want what's
the demand at that price QD let's apply
the price Q s so that's the excess
demand okay so now no it doesn't but it
does assume that B basically the market
and this comes to the trade off what's
the benefit of this policy which you've
raised with your question which is
equity which is I've defined consumer
surplus as simply being with the market
delivers so basically rich guys have
more consumer surplus than poor guys
okay that might not seem fair to people
okay as a result the benefit is equity
which is that if you that everyone gets
gas at a lower price rather the price
rise and the people who drop out may
actually not be the people who don't
need to drive the people can't afford to
drive so they drop out remember where
does the demand curve come from scums
utility maximization that's a
constrained maximization so the people
who drop out mate maybe people we want
maybe their people have to lose their
jobs as they can't drive to their jobs
anymore
that's unfortunate so basically the the
benefit of this is equity and that
raises something were to come back to
over and over again in this class which
is what we call the equity efficiency
trade-off okay the equity efficiency
trade-off which is there are many
government policies which make society
more equal but along the way deliver
deadweight loss and I'll actually tell
you later in the class how to optimize
across that problem how to optimize
across - trade-off between equity and
efficiency but for right now I just need
to understand that there's that there's
a trade-off okay yeah
in this milk ice feeling that the people
who are able to pay the most money will
yeah exactly so the point is right the
people who would do more dear it's a
different kind of inequity so if you're
worried about so in some sense the rich
guy would say well that's not fair to me
just because I've got a productive job I
could be doing and someone else has
extra time why should they get the gas
instead of me so you're right there's
always sort of an inequity I guess when
I say equity that's a great point when I
say could I implicitly mean what we call
that's actually a very important point
whatever say equity in this course I
implicitly mean what we call vertical
equity vertical equity is rich versus
poor okay there are other kinds of
equity you might care about like who has
extra time versus who doesn't have extra
time okay but and and that's a good
point but for now and I think I could
ever think about rich versus poor we
think about government policy equity
efficiency trade-off we really think
about vertical equity okay other
questions about that okay
so let's do a couple more examples to
drill this intuition home okay let's do
a couple more examples because this is a
very important point okay example a
let's talk about ticket scalping okay I
love going to I go I love going to music
concerts one of my 51st concert of the
year last year last night sorry went to
my 51st cars to here I love going a
music concert so I know a lot about the
music business and ticket scalping at
concerts a big deal for those who know
the term this is the idea of buying
tickets essentially on a secondary
market so let's use the example of Adele
so Adele about two years ago went on
tour for the first time in four years to
back up an incredibly successful album
and folks really want to see your life
because she had a big fan base she was
quiet for a while she made now whom
people really want to see her life she
wanted to make sure her fans could
afford to see her so what she did is she
said I'm gonna price tickets that many
tickets for $40 and the highest tickets
at 150 which is really really cheap so
my daughter's going to see Jay Cole
tonight and she's paying
like 150 for a mediocre ticket okay so
40 to 150 s really cheap okay
but she's saying I want to live our
consumer surplus to my fans I wanna make
sure my fans can really enjoy this enjoy
this I get surplus but what happened
well what happened is that the tickets
sold out instantly
like literally instantaneously and the
major purchasers were what we call
scalpers who are essentially
professionals who buy tickets and then
resell them on what we call the
secondary market you might have heard of
StubHub or other sites like that we're
essentially go on and buy tickets to
sold-out events and the prices on
StubHub were much higher there's about
$1,500 for a good ticket about ten times
what she'd set the price at so basically
who's getting a surplus not the fans the
scalpers the people who are quick enough
to get online who said box set up so the
second it went online they went online
and got the tickets they have thousands
of BOTS set up essentially somehow they
got around the click this if you're
human box I don't how they do that
but essentially I'm sure it's smart
programmers you guys can probably do
that in an hour as an extra credit
project okay they got around it and they
bought and so essentially Adele actually
didn't create surplus for her fans she
created surplus for scalpers okay now it
didn't used to be this way when I was a
kid we didn't have a secondary market
we waited online so when I saw my first
concert in 1981 you guys believe that
1981 I saw the cars
how many guys heard of the cars Oh God
anyway so the cars I had to wait on line
for hours to get tickets because that
was that was the allocation mechanism so
let's think about whether life is better
or worse because on the one hand
scalpers get money on the other hand
people don't waste time waiting online
so it really comes down to the same
equity trade-off we talked about before
now as a as a 16 year old 1981 I cannot
have afforded to pay probably the
secondary market price so I love but I
was just 16 I'd nothing do with my time
so I was happy to spend
I was waiting online okay but on the
other hand you could say someone is very
productive who was a big fan who was
very productive and could be out
inventing new products if they weren't
standing on line they might say that's
really inefficient I'm happy to pay
1,500 bucks to spend my time inventing
new things rather than have to sit
around waiting online so it's not clear
which is the better or the worse system
it's hard to say yeah well no but no
here's the point this that's a great
point which is that in some sense what
the scalpers do is undo Adele's action
and create a truly efficient market so
think of the scalper says essentially
undoing Adele's action which distorted
the market so you have it you have a
market for adele tickets which is an
echo or $1500 adele tried to set a price
ceiling at 150 seemingly selfishly
saying look I'm willing to give up my
surplus okay
I'm for my for my fans but a force
shouldn't work out that way what
happened was the market recall but at
1500 but that extra surplus didn't go to
Adele the consumer surplus still
remained above 1500 the difference was
that extra gaped 150 and 1500 didn't go
to dela went to the scalpers so it's
probably more efficient than waiting on
line because waiting in line has an
efficiency where's this instantaneous
bidding is more efficient but it in
substance is delivering that if the
efficiency gain is being delivered not
to consumers as Adele wanted it's being
delivered to scalpers okay so basically
now there's another alternative
what could the dell have done instead
what what's what's another way adele
could have approached this well she
could have auctioned her tickets online
she could have said look I know that I
can't manage deliver $40 tickets to my
fans
it just can't defeat the scalping system
but why so the scalpers have the money
I'm gonna auction my tickets and
essentially she could have set up an
efficient market online we will bid and
then you would have gotten the efficient
outcome and you wouldn't wait online you
would have bid now would have been
inequitable outcome
but basically the same fans would have
gotten the tickets as in the end got
them from the scalpers but instead it's
paying 1500 to the scalpers unpaid 1500
to Adele and probably that's a better
outcome I mean you know Adele doesn't
need the money but at the end of the day
if Adele's generating that amount of
goodwill from her fans it seems like she
should get the money not a bunch of
scalpers okay so I guess probably rather
have her have it than the scalpers now
ticketmasters tried to set up auction
systems recognizing this problem and
they're not really taking off and it
just it sort of speaks to the fact that
people don't really like to think about
economics okay so there was that
basically people are like yeah but if
you auction that's ripping off the fans
that's no fair and say why should I say
well you getting ripped off anyway just
by scalpers and they said no I can still
get online first and get my ticket and
people just didn't like it thought it
was unfair even though it's almost
certainly a better outcome for society
if they Goodell shut the money rabbin
the scalpers which speaks the fact that
you no morals matter in markets okay we
like think of these markets abstract a
moral concepts but morals do matter
okay and that basically it's sort of
matters you know you sometimes can't do
the right thing because it might not be
huh the thing that makes consumers
willing to participate okay so that's
one example scalping another example
food banks okay food banks our
organizations which are right oh yeah go
ahead
[Music]
yeah I thought about that so in my if I
could do anything I wanted in life I'd
be a rock star and I thought if I was a
rock star be cool I'd like have a
concert for like my mega fans or like
they'd have to prove who they were and I
have a bracelet and stuff it just seems
like it's too hard
it seems the technology is just too hard
so actually there's a really cool
example that's on the phone this morning
with a with a with a rock and roll
promoter who's doing a super cool thing
so as the election approaches I will nag
you guys to vote voter turnout among the
young is an enormous problem in the u.s.
so she is running a series of concerts
around the country where if you show a
picture of yourself outside a polling
place you get into the concert for free
to try to promote voting among young
people it's super cool it's called I
voted you can look it up on the web it's
kind of a cool thing there's a couple
concerts here in Boston they're all over
the country so you could think about
things like that the question is
ultimately you know two people
photoshopped a picture from the polling
place you know it's all it's it's just a
question of enforcement okay so it's
about food banks so basically um these
are organizations provide free food to
the poor and with the biggest one is
called feeding America feeding America
has food banks all over the nation and
they provide free food free food to the
poor okay
now their goal then is they have to
figure out where to send the food to get
the people who need it the most
now a market does this naturally
basically if people want more Turkey in
location a then also in the price for
turkey goes up all of a sudden the store
runs out of Turkey it says wow I can
charge more for Turkey it raises the
price and it a club relates the market
so a market solves for sending the right
food to where people want it but the
problem with feeding America is that
they didn't have that market so this had
decide where to send stuff and they'd
screw up they'd like to send potatoes to
Idaho we're like they're drowning the
potatoes stuff like that so it was very
hard from the figure out where to send
the food exactly what people wanted the
most because they didn't have the market
mechanism they want to give it away for
free that sort of defeat the purse they
charge for it but they didn't really
know they didn't have the market to tell
them where folks wanted which foods in
the real market if you want real foods
you bid the price up
in their market you couldn't so feeding
America came up with a really clever
solution they made a virtual market they
said to each food bank we are gonna give
you a fake budget of X hundred thousands
of dollars and you bid for which foods
you want based on what the people in
your area want and will then allocate it
according to those bids so they got the
market mechanism working without the
food banks haven't actually give any
money okay
so in that way they massively
reallocated food they suddenly said hey
the one from Idaho is bidding really
high for Turkey and not all for potatoes
maybe we should send them more turkey
and seven potatoes elsewhere so they
essentially got market signals from a
non financial transaction it was super
cool idea and the amount of and there
was a huge benefit they were able to
effectively allocate about 50 million
pounds of food through this mechanism
making sure that food got to the folks
that needed it so there's an example you
can use a market mechanism without
actually while while not violating
equity the food was always free but if I
set up these virtual prices they managed
to get the food delivered to where
people who want the most they let the
market send its allocated signals they
let the market be allocated li efficient
sent signals of where people wanted the
food without actually violating equity
okay
questions about that okay now let's go
to the hardest but my favorite example
which is taxi medallions this is a hard
example but it's a really cool one and
it ends with a great story okay taxi
cabs now cast your mind back pre ubirr
okay go back ten years about ten years
taxi cabs were the only way you could
get around town if you didn't have you
know if you want to get from one eighty
point be in a car you known one you took
a taxi okay and this was a great example
of an economist perfectly competitive
market in theory it's the identical
product you want to go from point A to
point B okay
it's very there's could be lots of them
are riding around the streets you can
price compare because cabs are coming by
all the
I'm okay it should have been a very
effective perfectly efficient perfectly
competitive market okay but it wasn't
because every city limited the amount of
taxicabs that were allowed in their city
every city had a system where to be a
taxicab you had to have what was called
the medallion rather than really
Manhattan's if its original Medina is
there's a piece of paper actually and
they regulated the number of taxicabs
allowed in the city they said we're only
going to allow X many taxicab drivers in
the city in every city did this now
we're gonna do both a positive and
normative analysis of this policy let's
start with a positive analysis what did
this polity jit policy do okay now I'm
gonna go figure 10 for figure 10 four
will be one of the most complicated
figures doing this class so I'm gonna go
through two slowly as I can but please
stop me if it's not clear okay this one
of these figures will go back and forth
between the two sides so on the right
hand side is the market on the left hand
side as a cab firm we're gonna start by
assuming all cabs are identical we
assume all cabs are identical so one
representative firm tells us about every
cat firm okay now we start with the
market we have an initial demand which
is d the line d the blue line is the
demand for taxi cabs okay an initial
supply curve s1 we're gonna assume that
essentially in a perfectly competitive
market you have a flat long run supply
curve your perfectly elastic supply okay
anybody can just grab a cab and starts
right what's getting in a cab burger
without medallions anyone could throw
can throw a taxi sign in the car so
drive we're not picking people up okay
so it's effectively perfectly
entry-and-exit so it's a perfectly
competitive long run market therefore
flat supply that's one so our initial
equilibrium is that point big e one okay
when you have q1 rides big q1 rides per
month and that amounts to so so you have
Q that's the equilibrium now how many
firms are there well we know any firms
there are because we say okay at that
price p1 we go to the left
we know that firms will produce where
marginal cost equals average
that the minimum of long-run average
cost we proved that a couple lectures
ago
therefore if the price is a 1 we know
each efficient firm will produce little
q1 if there's if each firms could reduce
a little q1 and the total amount of
rides is gonna be big q1 then that
implies little n1 firms so let me go
through it again supply equals demand a
big Q one that gives you a price P one
now we shift to the left at that price P
1 we know that each firm will choose to
produce little q1 rides because that's
where price equals marginal cost equals
average cost now we go back to the right
we know if this little each firms racing
little q1 rides and you need big q1 then
there must be n1 firms ok questions
about that that's the initial
equilibrium okay and at that point there
are long-run zero profits consumer
surplus is a plus B plus both seat bus C
C by the way is the gray area on either
side of the dash line a plus B plus C
we'd mark it twice because it's
confusing the dashed line there so the
blue area of the green area in the gray
area are the consumer surplus and what's
the producer surplus
what's the Bri surplus raise your hand
and tell me yeah zero because yeah
there's no it's in long run equilibrium
there's no profits in long run person
kinetic the Librium price remember
profits are price minus average cost but
price equals average cost okay so
there's no profit so it's all consumer
surplus all well and good now let's say
the government comes in and says we're
gonna have a medallion system
okay
so let's so let's say um we're gonna
wait a minute system we're gonna have a
system where only the little N two cabs
are allowed in the market little n 2 are
the only number of cabs allowed in the
market okay so what is the new market
supply curve start on the right what's
do the market supply curve well up to
little n 2 times Q 1 nothing's changed
each cab company used to provide Q what
little Q 1 rides at a price P 1 so up to
the point little and too little Q 1
we're on the same supply curve we used
to be on but then things change why do
they change because now let's say riders
want more than little n 2 Q 1
well you can't deal with that by entry
you have to deal with that by the
existing cab drivers working more but if
they work more supply curve is upward
sloping because now marginal costs can
be rising before the resupply curve was
flat is when you went to the right of
little and to little Q 1 as you move to
the right
you just got more entering and everyone
still produces their efficient level of
little Q 1 now when you can't allow more
entry firms have to produce more and
suddenly they're not at the cost
minimizing point they're riding up their
marginal cost curve so the supply curve
becomes flat to that point and then
becomes upward sloping and that's s2 s2
is the red line that is flat to the left
of n little n to little Q 1 and then
becomes Verbeek um ZUP words sloping and
the new equilibrium is that point e 2
with n 2 firms by law you can only then
two firms pricing little Q two rides
each okay and your new equilibrium is
big Q 2 and that new equilibrium price
is the new equilibrium price is P 2 the
director over in price is P 2 okay now P
2 if you go to the old um P 2 is the
point if you look at the prices P 2 but
I forget the AC 2 curve focus on the AC
1 curve
okay average the average cost function
hasn't changed it's still a c1 so if
their price is p2 and their average cost
curve is a c1 there could produce where
price equals marginal cost at little e2
okay so let me back up you have let's go
back to the front curve on the right the
equilibrium is not Big E - that's sort
of priced a little P - now shift to the
left at a price of little P - firms
produce where price equals marginal cost
right price equals marginal cost at a
quantity little Q - so firms produce a
little Q - because that's the point at
which price equals marginal cost
they produce it a little Q - well if
they're making little Q two units at a
price P - they're earning profits of Pi
the shaded area because they are
producing units at price above marginal
cost and they're producing little Q two
units so every unit they produce turning
profits on so the taxi medallion workers
are the taxi companies are now making
money they're making profits okay
questions about that yeah they're making
profits so imagine where we started at E
- in allowed free entry then you'd see
basically more firms whenever you drive
the price down to p1 but we don't allow
that
so there's profits it's a barrier to
entry which creates profits which breaks
us from our long-run flat supply curve
we talked about one of the reasons why
that loop will be flat so now let's move
to the normative is this a good idea or
not well let's look at the welfare
implications what's happened what's
happened is consumers used to have a
surplus a plus B plus C now their
surplus is what what's to do consumer
surplus raise their hand and tell me
yeah
just a because the line below the demand
above price is just a producer's used to
have zero surplus what's their new
surplus behind you yeah B because it's
the area above the supply curve below
the price line and C is what the
deadweight loss
those the transactions no longer
happening okay
the deadweight loss okay so basically
normatively you can pose the problem as
the following is it worth society losing
the area see in order to transfer the
area be from consumers to taxicab
drivers that's the way to think about
this problem we say it again it's very
important central the government policy
doing is saying I'm going to transfer be
from consumers to producers even though
it's gonna cost me see and deadweight
loss that's what the government's saying
that's the government's position okay
now why is the government wrong why in
fact is that not the proper statement of
what happens it's very complicated what
is the government miss when it says hey
look I've made the drivers better off
sure I've created deadweight lost
beliefs and I made consumers will help
at least I mean these drivers better off
they leave terrible lives as article in
the paper all the time about suicides
the taxicab drivers it's terrible what
do they miss yeah they've missed the
fact that the taxicab drivers have to
buy the medallions that the limited
numbered aliens aren't just given the
taxicab drivers they're bought and the
taxicab drivers what is a taxicab driver
willing to pay for a medallion they are
willing to pay in the limit the total
surplus they get from driving the cab -
a dollar or - some amount you know that
they need to eat so if suddenly in a
world with no restrictions with no tax
cab medallions if you said we're gonna
be a piece of paper should you drive a
taxi but anyone could have it for free
whoa would it be worth zero but in the
world will you say you can if you have
the speed paper you can drive and
drivers earn profits pie what will the
taxed have medallions sell for pie -
some small amount so actually who wins
the taxicab medallion owners and who are
they they are random folks who happen to
get these things in 1920 when they were
issued and there
descendants and people who bought them
okay so this leads to my great story the
taxicab medallion king of Long Island
was the guy who happened to have a bun
Chee's tax cabinets and as they went
through the roof they are worth a lot in
New York a tax New York um had 12,000
permits and that number did not change
since they originally sold for $10 each
in 1937 937 you could have bought her
for $10 they issued 12 12,000
they've never increased it right now a
tax Hammond I New York is worth $400,000
okay well the tax cap king of New York
is a guy lives Long Island who made so
much money that he actually uh he
actually first kids Bar Mitzvah
not only had rented at a hotel ho
basketball theme Bar Mitzvah but hired
Nicki Minaj okay
this was paid for by area B okay this
was paid for so in fact it's not the
taxi cab drivers that make at under this
policy it's a taxi cab medallion king of
La Llorona in who's the big loser not
the taxicab drivers the taxi cab
medallion owners so everyone tells you
burrs a bad thing because these poor
taxi cab drivers are starving taxi cab
drivers were always starving it was
always a terrible life the difference
the difference is price and medallions
is down like 50% and I cry no tears for
the for the Nicki Minaj higher in class
of America okay so basically when you
think about P per se
Uber's bad it steals jobs tax time
drivers no it doesn't okay it steals
money from tax cab medallion owners and
that is something we might be okay with
so feel fine taking your uber it's a
great it's a great thing so let me stop
there
um I'm going to come back come back next
lecture and we will start talking about
monopoly the market structure not the
game